SEPARATE FROM THE DOSSIER.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
A LONG-TIME ADVISER TO HILLARY
CLINTON JOINS US TONIGHT.
I KEEP A RUNNING LIST ON THE
THINGS WE HAVE LEARNED.
THIS IS A COMPLETE LIST.
WE LEARNED THAT PAUL MANAFORT,
KIND OF SLEAZY IN THE BUSINESS
TRUMP AGREED WE SHOULD CHANGE
RUSSIA POLICY AND THEY CALLED
THE DIPLOMATS.
WE LEARNED RUSSIA BOUGHT
$100,000 IN FACEBOOK AD AND
R.T. FUNDED IN PART BY THE
PUTIN GOVERNMENT.
I KNEW ALL OF THAT BEFORE.
WHERE IS THE COLLUSION PART
THAT JUSTIFIED THIS WHOLE
EXERCISE?
>> THAT IS THE PART THAT
MUELLER IS STILL LOOKING AT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY LOOKING AT
THIS IS A CRAZY LONG TIME.
LOOK AT WHITE WATER.
LOOK AT BENGHAZI.
EIGHT COMMITTEES.
>> Tucker: IS THE WHITEWATER
INVESTIGATION A MODEL YOU WANT
TO SEE REPLICATED?
>> I THINK ROBERT MUELLER WAS
PICKED FOR THE JOB BECAUSE HIS
DEG ANITY AND BECAUSE OF HIS
HE WAS PICKED --
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE
ATTACKING MUELLER.
>> NO, LOOK.
THIS SHOW CALLED FOR HIM TO BE
FIRED OR ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
I'M MORE INTERESTED WITH THOSE
BARKING LIKE DOGS FOR LAST
YEAR ABOUT HOW RUSSIA
DONALD TRUMP WAS IN LEAGUE
WITH RUSSIA.
IF ANY OF THAT WERE TRUE I'D
BE UPSET ABOUT IT.
NONE OF IT TURNS OUTS TO BE
TRUE AND NO ONE ADMITS THEY
WERE WRONG.
IT WAS ALL A LIE.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT IS TRUE.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS.
WHETHER RUSSIA MEDDLED IN THE
ELECTION.
AND WHETHER DONALD TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN HAD ANYTHING TO DO
MULER IS LOOKING AT.
FLYNN PLED GUILTY.
>> WHAT DID HE PLEAD GUILTY --
>> HOLD ON.
WHAT DID HE PLEAD GUILTY TO?
TO PERJURY?
>> HE PLED GUILTY TO LYING --
I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND
IMPEACHMENT OF BILL CLINTON OR
WHITE WATER.
APPRECIATION FOR HOW FAR
AFIELD THE INVESTIGATIONS CAN
GO AND THE COST TO THE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS THE POINT I'M MAKING.
IF THERE IS COLLUSION --
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT
BENGHAZI.
BENGHAZI WENT ON FOR FOUR
>> Tucker: HERE IS MY POINT.
I'M NOT HERE TO SAY THAT THE
BENGHAZI INVESTIGATION BORE
FRUIT.
MY POINT IS --
>> I HAVE GOT AN ADMISSION
FROM YOU TONIGHT.
>> I NEVER SAID ANYTHING OTHER
THAN THAT.
THE CHARGE HERE IS THAT THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH
THE FOREIGN GOVERNMENT TO
SUBVERT DEMOCRACY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT IS TREASON.
THAT IS A CHARGE REPEATED BY A
LOT OF LEADERS ON THE
>> AND STEVE BANNON.
>> MAYBE STEVE BANNON, TOO.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF IT.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT ROBERT
MUELLER DOES OR DOESN'T KNOW.
HE IS DOING HIS JOB.
HIS JOB IS NOT TO TELL US
EVERYTHING.
>> IT'S THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
PRESS CORPS.
>> NOTHING ELSE MATTERS RIGHT
NOW EXCEPT FOR BOB MUELLER.
>> DOES IT BOTHER YOU --
HIM TIME AND SPACE TO DO HIS
JOB.
>> Tucker: HE HAS SPACE.
HE HAS UNLIMITED BUDGET.
>> THERE IS AN EXPIRATION DATE
ON THIS.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE IT.
>> LOOK AS AN AMERICAN --
>> YOU DON'T GET TO CHOOSE --
>> Tucker: AS AN AMERICAN
WHO LIVED THROUGH THIS
YOURSELF WOULD IT BOTHER YOU
IF AT THE END OF THE
INVESTIGATION YOU GET PEOPLE
FOR CRIMES COMMITTED BEFORE
THE CAMPAIGN, OR PEOPLE LIKE
GENERAL FLYNN WITH A STATEMENT
AGAINST THE F.B.I. AND PERJURY
CHARGE.
NOBODY WAS CHARGED FOR CORE
ALLEGATION.
>> SO FAR.
>> Tucker: DO YOU BELIEVE
SOMEONE WILL BE CHARGED?
>> I BELIEVE WE WILL FIND OUT
BECAUSE WE WILL GIVE ROBERT
MUELLER THE TIME.
HE WILL TAKE THE TIME.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
MANAFORT AND FLYNN AND
PAPADOPOULOS.
THESE GUYS, FLYNN, WHAT HE DID
CAMPAIGN.
PAPADOPOULOS WAS DURING THE
PAPADOPOULOS, THE MODEL U.N.
GUY.
LET'S BE REAL.
OKAY?
FLYNN WAS A REAL GUY.
>> NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER.
>> Tucker: KEY ADVISER ON
THE CAMPAIGN.
PAPADOPOULOS HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANY --
TO LYING IN AN INTERVIEW.
>> IT'S POSSIBLE HE TOLD THE
TRADITIONS OF DEMOCRACY?
>> YES.
LEGALLY AND OTHERWISE.
I THINK THE GUYS ARE LUCKY
THAT BEING NAIVE ISN'T
CRIMINAL.
THEM.
>> Tucker: IS THERE EVIDENCE
THEY DID SOMETHING WRONG.
NOT NAIVE OR STUPID BUT WHAT
WAS WRONG?
I'M CONFUSED.
>> MEETINGMEETING WITH THE AGENT
>> MEETINGMEETING WITH THE AGENS
>> MEETINGMEETING WITH THE AGENO
>> MEETINGMEETING WITH THE AGENF
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TO
PROVIDE OPPOSITION RESEARCH ON
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE IS
PROBABLY NOT THE MOST --
>> REALLY?
UP THERE TO PAY MONEY FOR A
LAW FIRM THAT PAID RUSSIAN
AGENTS WITH THE HILLARY
CAMPAIGN?
>> IT'S UP THERE WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY COMMISSIONING
THAT REPORT.
>> Tucker: IT WASN'T THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> IT WAS THE REPUBLICAN
ORGANIZATION.
>> A GUY WHO HATED TRUMP.
A HEDGE FUND BILLIONAIRE
DIDN'T LIKE TRUMP.
>> STEELE WHO IS A RENOWN
BRITISH INTELLIGENT AGENT.
GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM, WHY DON'T
HAVE THEY HIM IN OPEN COURT?